في قراءه في احد المرات انك اردتي ان
تموتي بسبب هذه الصوره هل هذا صحيح اولا
وهل يمكن ان يكون هذا لانك رفضتي في تلك
الفتره على سبيل المثال سوره الضحيه
الابديه والمثاليه ولكن لاحقا يعني عرفت
كيف
تتماشين مع الاهداف التي ارد فيها من خلال
هذه الصوره
نعم صحيح انني تعلمت ان اكون دائما
ايجابيه لكن عندما اتذكر تلك القصه في
ايامها الاولى فانني اتذكر كيف انني في
التاسعه من العمر لم يكن لدي اي خيار
واصبحت ضحيه حرب لقد كنت ناجيه من عنف
الحروب ولكنني الان مدافعه وحاشده للسلام
لقد جربت كيف ان الغضب والكراهيه في قلبي
دمر اشياء كثيره جميله في حياتي ولو استمر
ذلك لا استمر في تدمير حياه في حاضر
والمستقبل وهذا ليس امرا جيدا لهذا فقد
وجدت الطريق الذي يؤدي بي اما الى تغيير
شيء جذري من اعماق قلبي واما الى الموت
بالكراهيه بالتاكيد يعني مفهومه طفله
عمرها تسع سنوات لن تكون مرتاحه لالتقاط
هذا النوع من الصور لكن لو تحدثين اكثر عن
هذه الصوره تحديدا اين التقطت اين كنت متى
رايتيها اول مره اصلا الصوره
الجنوب فيتنام وفي الايام الاولى من يونيو
من عام
1972 اقتحم الجنود الاعداء القريه وكانوا
يحتلون المنازل بما فيها منزلنا ولذلك فقد
قررنا على عجل الى معبدنا المحلي لاننا
كنا نعتقد انه مكان مقدس وبالتالي سيكون
امنا لجانا اليه لكن كما تعلمون اكتشفت
انه لا يوجد مكان امن زمن الحرب
بقيت اسرنا مقتبئه داخل المعبد لمده ثلاثه
ايام تماما مثل مع عبد اخرى في قرى اخرى
وفي اليوم الثالث وتحديدا في الثامن مليون
اتذكر انه بعد ان تناولنا الغداء كنا
باعتبارنا اطفال نلهو حيث كان مسموح لنا
باللعب داخل ساحه المعبد بالقرب من الملجا
وفجاه سمعنا صراخ الجنود ورجال يطلبون منا
الفرار و الابتعاد عن المعبد بسرعه لانهم
تلقوا معلومات تفيد انه سيكون عرضه للقذف
لذلك تعاين علينا ان نهرب باسرع ما يمكن
لقد بدات في العدو مع اخوتي صوب الطريق
الرئيسي وبمجرد بلوغنا الطريق السريع
الاول كان بامكاننا رؤيه طائره بصدد
التحليق وسماعه هذه المحركاتها الذي يصم
الاذان لقد كانت على مسافه قريبه من
رؤوسنا رفعت راسي الى السماء ورايت بام
عيني كيف ان اربع عيله سوداء كانت بصدد
الوقوع منها ثم بدات اصوات الانفجارات
فجاه اثر ذلك تنير تلتهم كل شيء من حولي
حتى انها وصلت الى ثياب والتهمتها وبدات
حريق جسدي اول ما رايت كان ذراعي يسرا
والسنه النار عليها فاستخدمت يدي اليمنى
لمحاوله اطفائها ولذلك احترقت يد اليمنى
وما زلت حتى اليوم احمل اثار ذلك في تلك
اللحظه اكتشفت ان الجزء العلوي من جسدي
اصابته نيران ولكن المعجزه ان رجلي بقيتها
سليمتين ولم تصل هما الالسنه لذلك كنت
قادره على العدو حتى رايت شقيقه واقاربي
وبعض الجنود هناك فاستمرارنا في الجاري ثم
الجاري ثم الجري لا نلوى على شيء استغرق
ذلك فتره ما شعرت اثرها انني لم اقعد
قادره على استمرار في العدو فتوقفت واصبحت
اصرخ من الحراره حاول احد الجنود مساعدتي
اعطاني الماء لاشرب ثم سكب الماء على جسدي
ولم يكن يعرف ان ذلك سيزيد من ايه الواضع
لذلك فان التصاق النا بالماء جعل وضعي
اسوا بكثير ولذلك فقدت الوعي بسبب الالم
الفظيع ولم اعد اي شيء من حوله همم لا
نقيل في التقارير انه المصور الذي التقط
الصوره هو من قام بعمليه الانقاذ لاحقا
بعد ان شعره بخطوره الوضع الذي كنت تعانين
منها الان بعد كل هذه السنوات ومرورها مين
بتعتقدي هو اللي ضرب النابال هل هي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ام فيتنام
الشماليه انا ذاك
فمي
في الواقع بالنسبه لك طفله عندما كبرت
عرفت ان الولايات المتحده هي التي نفذت
الهجوم هي وجنود من فيتنام الجنوبيه الذين
كانوا يقاتلون فيتنام الشماليه وعندما جاء
الجنود الشماليون ليحتل القريه نص قد ضباط
الجنوب مع الولايات المتحده وابلغهم بوجود
اولئك الجنود الاعداء هذا ما حدث لم ارى
هويه قائد الطائره في الحقيقه ولكن معرفته
لاحقا ان النبال كان السلاح متوفرا فقط
لدى الولايات المتحده